winter is coming and the tension keeps
on ratcheting up oh keeper we've got
another really good episode with this
one and things just they keep moving
forward to keep ratcheting up the stakes
keep getting raised and alliances keep
shifting quite a bit especially at
King's Landing and so it's surprising to
me we get an answer to the question of
who laid out the events of a couple
episodes ago again I still can't talk
about what it was that happened but we
find out who was involved in who was
behind that a bit sooner than I would
have expected who it actually turns out
to be was not shocking but cool it all
panned out well I mean the rationale
worked for me the who was who was
actually involved makes total sense now
that I actually know who it is it's
probably better than in string it out
into like some sort of long season
mystery because it would have been
anticlimactic couple episodes wait then
we get the answers yeah it feels good
give him what the answers are we get
some great key moments with Elena Tyrell
and with Marjorie Marjorie she is god
she's so good I just work you people
manipulating them and just making it
feel real making it feel natural I've
talked about this before and she's she
does more of it everything going on with
the Lannisters is really interesting and
sort of the dynamic and seeing this
family fray apart this family that has
seemed so tightly knit up to this point
I mean yeah they didn't all like each
other so much but they always seemed
united in their goals now yeah I don't
know so much I feel like you need to
touch on what happened with Searcy and
Jamie again I don't want to get into the
specifics of it I talked about some of
the aspects of it that bothered me last
time I wasn't as bothered by it as a lot
of people so a lot of people really
really took it hard I wasn't thrilled
with it I take it as harshly as a lot of
people did that said it was kind of
gonna ride on how it played out after
that for me as to whether or not it was
really gonna work and it kind of seems
like they're ignoring it like this thing
happened that should have a really major
impact on these characters in it it
doesn't seem to have done that and that
makes me dislike it a bit more why
didn't it when the whole thing happened
last episode it was kind
we'll see how they play out the
aftermath of this well the kind of is no
aftermath the dynamic hasn't changed at
all
and that makes me just feel that the
whole thing just wasn't worth it
Lord Baelish came back last episode and
he still doing his his thing again and
you know what every time he's on screen
after he's seen I feel like you need to
shower he's just so slimy I mean that as
the greatest compliment of this actor in
this character because that's what he
needs to be and it just works
wonderfully
John snow continues to be forming into a
leader character that I'm actually
enjoying after the events of last season
he just seems to have lost a lot of his
innocence he's much more jaded he's much
more worldly and it just feels more
earned now what they're trying to do
with his character versus where it
seemed like they were going in previous
seasons now I'm like yeah yeah I dig it
and we got locked that sneaky bugger who
cut off Jaime's hand last season well
he's back and doing some interesting
stuff too we actually spent a fair
amount of time at Craster's keep which
is where the mutiny happened last season
with the with the members of the Nights
Watch and it really makes you feel
really uncomfortable whenever we're at
Castle black
see how bad these guys can go if they
just don't have a strong hand to keep
them in place it's really best
exemplified by this guy burn gorman
who's always good I remember him as the
guy with the weird mouth from Torchwood
but he gives an edge in a layer of
interest to a character who really
should just be a throw away also north
of the wall we get a little more insight
into the White Walkers and it's not a
deep bit of insight I mean you're never
gonna get a ton of depth to these guys
they I think it's pretty obvious they
are always gonna be just villains
they're just evil they're something
that's always gonna be a problem there
isn't gonna be layers and depths and
humanity to them there isn't supposed to
be but we are seeing more of sort of how
they function in sort of logistical
sense and it's nice just to get little
doses of of them and get a little more
sense of what they are and how they do
what they do I mean we still don't have
a full picture not even close but these
little nuggets they're nice and they
sort of just open up the world a little
bit as far as these creatures go and it
makes you makes you more scared of them
to be frank across the Narrow Sea we
have Daenerys doing our thing
yet another slaver city it's really just
fun watching a roll through this whole
slavers Bay area and see her taking on
what she sees as a severe deep injustice
in the world and of course it's just
building your forces more and more to
eventually go after the Iron Throne and
Westeros and I just cannot wait for that
to happen this was one of those really
building everything up episodes but it
just builds everything I'm really well
and it's enjoyable unto itself aside
from the really total dropping of the
ball in terms of the follow-up of COC
and Jamie's dynamic together aside from
that really good really solid episode
really looking forward to the next one
so let me ask you this and this is a
question for those who are watching the
show not who have read the books and
already know the answers but who do you
think is gonna be the next major
character to bite the dust drop
something down in the comments on either
who you think it is or who you think it
should be who you'd like to see and when
I say a major character I mean someone
who whose name is in the opening credits
of the show and ideally who's been
around for more than one season who do
you think is gonna bite an X or who do
you want to see bite it drop something
down in the comments let's talk about it
and until next time this council is
adjourned